The next tool I'd like to talk about in optimization tools
is how to bulk edit number of assets.
Now let's say, for example, you want
to adjust all of the texture compression settings,
or maybe some of your textures
are not put into the correct texture group.
While you could open up each one individually
and apply this information, this
can be tedious, especially if you have
hundreds of textures to adjust.
The Bulk Edit option allows you
to select many textures inside of the Content Browser.
Then we can right-click on them, go to Asset Actions,
and select the Edit Selection and Property Matrix.
This will then open up those textures inside
of the Property Matrix, which looks like the following image.
And then from there, we can adjust their properties
on the right-hand side of the Pinch column.
And it will adjust the properties
that we have for our textures.
Let's go ahead and take a look at how we do this in the editor.
So we're going to come here and hit Control-Space.
I'm going to make sure my Content folder is selected.
I'm going to grab just Textures.
And for now, I'm going to hit Underscore In because I
know that there's a number of normal maps here.
So I'm just going to select these first five,
right-click, and then Asset Actions, Edit Selection
and Property Matrix.
Now that I've done that, you're
going to see that it does come up.
And let's come over here and adjust something
like the LOD Bias.
I'm just going to set this to a value of 1.
And if we hit this pin here, we'll
see that the LOD Bias has been, in fact, set to 1.
And we can further check this by hovering
over each one of the textures.
You can see the LOD Bias has been set to 1.
And just as easily to remove that,
if we just set this to 0 again, we're
going to set everything in here back to 0.
So you can see how easy that is, especially
if you have hundreds of assets that you wish to do.
Now, the last thing that I want to note about this tool,
and I said this in the beginning,
but this is very important.
This only works on things of the same asset type.
So if I want to work on static meshes,
I need to make sure I have static meshes selected.
If I want to work on skeletal meshes,
I need to make sure I only have skeletal meshes.
Same with textures.
Making sure that you only have the right asset selected
will ensure that all the properties are displayed
and the tool works exactly how you need it to.